pleased to say that the leveling up and
housing secretary Michael Gove is with
us now good morning thanks for joining
us on the program this morning moldy
houses
um you I believe are suggesting that
organizations like those in Rochdale
should get their money cut because of
moldy houses how does that help people
who need to rely on these associations
well housing associations should be
looking after their tenants first and
we're not giving money to people who are
not even looking after their existing
properties to build new properties
they've got to make sure that they look
after their tenants
um it would be I think wrong of us to
give public money to an organization
that is failing until it gets its uh its
own act together but how does cutting
money to them help them do that well
this is money that is there for them to
get uh building new homes if you can't
even run the homes properly that you are
currently responsible for then you
certainly can't be building new homes
and this money will be used across the
country in order to build new homes but
Rochdale by a white housing they're not
getting it because they failed as as
you've reported Kate in this horrific
case and they've got to make sure that
they are spending the money they've got
effectively at the moment before we give
them any more but if you give them more
they can build better housing stock well
this is about new homes and existing
homes and the critical thing is they
have the money they need they've got the
resources they need in order to deal
with the problems that are currently
preoccupying me and so many others it is
not right that taxpayers money should go
to allow an organization to expand
particularly an organization that was
paying its chief executive north of 150
000 pounds they should not be getting
extra cash until they use the money they
already have to improve housing and I'm
saying to all housing associations that
their responsibility is to deal with the
damp the mold and some of the other
problems that have been identified by
campaigners that are meaning that there
are uh you know uh thousands of tenants
who are living in homes which are not
fit for human habitation
um where do you stand on the argument
about building 300 000 new homes a year
because it seems to be splitting the
party at the moment and thus the
government um we all know that we need
to build new homes I think there's a
consensus about how we build new homes
there's a conversation
um about how we make sure that the
tanning system works better and some of
the uh concerns that have been raised to
concerns that only have two we need to
make sure that when we build new homes
that they're beautiful and high quality
we also need to make sure that we
Safeguard um Greenfield sites wherever
possible and prioritize our housing on
Brownfield sites that's both good for
cities helping them to regenerate it's
good for the environment too Greenfield
sites wherever possible does that mean
that you would uh Brownfield sites
wherever possible sorry you said
Greenfield starts you said that wherever
possible you won't build on greenfields
exactly so yes but you you are not
ruling out building on some Greenfield
sites if necessary uh well the green
belt is protected but the priority
always is Brownfield first and then last
year
um the the balance has been tilted in
favor of Brownfield sites in a more
profound way than ever before but there
is there is more to do and as I say it's
both good for cities we've seen great
cities like Manchester revive and grow
with more people living in the Town
Center as a result of regeneration we
are trying to do that elsewhere with the
help of local government and the help of
an organization called homes England
that's got millions of pounds to help to
do that
um and that is not only good for those
cities and good for leveling up as we
encourage the great cities in the
Midlands and the north to grow it also
helps to relieve the pressure on uh
green fields that is good for the
environment as I say you're a very busy
man I heard you in the House of Commons
earlier in the week um saying that you
feel sorry for younger people than you
do potentially for pensioners that's not
going to go down very well with the
Bedrock of conservative supporters does
it um well my mum and dad are pensioners
and I'm naturally on their side but one
of the points that I was making is we
have to recognize that over the course
of in the last few years for a variety
of reasons partly the rest of you have
covered young people are having a a
challenging time and I want to make sure
that we extend opportunity to the Next
Generation and that means both building
the homes that they need but also making
sure that we get our economy onto an
even Keel um after the the turbulence of
covid and the war in Ukraine and provide
them with the opportunities that they
need in order to succeed in the future
talk to me about Michelle moan what do
you remember about the PPE contract with
Michelle moon when she approached you
how did that conversation go well during
the pandemic there were lots of people
who were approaching us with offers of
PPE I referred all of them to the
appropriate Civil Service channels in
order to make sure that the uh PPE that
we were being offered was of sufficient
quality and could be sourced in time it
was a procurement process which every
offer went through in order to assess
she did approach you with your personal
email no well lots of people approach to
be um
yeah there were lots of people who
approached me whether it was through
email text
um or uh or uh uh in the precincts of
the House of Commons or wherever to uh
uh say that they could help us because
as you'll remember at the time
um not just in the United Kingdom
um but across Europe uh we needed to
Source PPE quickly
um and uh anyone who approached me I
said thank you very much and made sure
that uh their uh their efforts to help
were referred to the appropriate
officially run independent channel to
assess whether or not the PPE that they
were offering um was value for money so
what do you remember about the personal
email that she sent you
um uh that she was one of uh a huge
number of people who were approaching
the government at the time uh who were
so you don't remember specifically her
approaching you uh I remember lots of
people approaching me you remember her
specifically approaching you I do
remember the thing about um baroness
moon is that uh uh uh you know as you
know she's a strong personality
um but there were lots and lots of other
people who approached me as well anyone
who approached me I thanked and then
made sure that they went through the
appropriate process so that anyone's
claim was assessed not by me as an
individual but by an independent process
okay but what do you remember about her
personal approach to you what do you
remember about that email uh that I
remember that she was uh Keen to ensure
that uh PPE which the government needed
at that time was provided
so you can't remember exactly what she
said uh well lots of people approached
me at the time I'm asking about her
specifically yeah I know and I'm saying
that lots of people approached me so uh
uh what I can recall is that she said
that the uh there was an organization
that she believed would be able to
provide PPE for the government and I
said to her as I said to everyone thank
you very much that's very kind we do
need PPE but I'm not the person who can
make that decision as to whether or not
this contract should be awarded okay but
you did forward on that uh that contact
and yeah as I did with lots of people
because
specifically about her how do you feel
about the fact that millions of pounds
was wasted because of that introduction
well uh I don't know uh uh the detail of
what happened once that uh bid was
referred because it was nothing to do
not my question Minister my question is
how do you feel about the fact that
millions of pounds were subsequently
wasted because of an introduction that
you uh were first approached and then
made to other members of government
wasted in what way well because
apparently it was quite a lot of it
wasn't fit for purpose well again that I
regret the fact that any PPE that was
purchased was not fit for purpose but my
recollection is that the overwhelming
majority of PPE that we did uh by was
fit for purpose at that time we're
talking about this specific case and it
was a 200 million pound contract
um some suggestions that she made 19
million pounds personally you know
that's at alleged I don't have the facts
that can confirm that or otherwise but
what we can say is a lot of that PBE was
subsequently not fit for purpose and it
was in introduction through you how do
you feel about that in hindsight
um well I regret the fact that any PPE
that we sourced was not fit for purpose
but the job that I was doing at the time
was to make sure that at the time when
uh we were facing a terrible pandemic
that anyone who wanted to help anyone
who was making an offer of PPE was
referred to the right channel I would
have hoped that you or I if someone said
I can provide PPE that we would have
said great the thing to do is to go to
this official government process to go
through this procurement gateway to have
the quality of uh the contract that
you're seeking to secure assess I
understand but I'm asking how sorry you
are now that actually all that money was
wasted because of an introduction that
was made by you
um I
the first thing I was going to say is
that
um I introduced lots of people so of
course I regret the fact that there was
any that was wasted but but what you're
trying to imply is that um it was I'm
just asking how you feel about it I mean
I would be mortified if it had been me
um uh because because there's a lot of
money that's been wasted yes of course
it is and of course the one of the
things is that none of us want that
money to be wasted but the the uh the
problems that we had with PPE at the
time meant that we were anxious to scale
contracts from everyone the fact that
some contracts meant that some of the
material that was uh procured was not
upstairs a decision that was made in
haste
um well everyone was making that
decision it's correct everyone's making
that decision on the basis of what
individual organizations put forward and
what the independent process decided I
did not decide
to award that contract
you didn't you're right I'm talking
about energy
are you having my water yes
I wonder how you're saving energy at
home because the Chancellor's telling us
that we need to save 15 on our energy
bills what are you going to do uh well
at home I try to you as much as possible
make sure that uh I turn down the
thermostat uh that I uh limit my energy
use but again I'm conscious that uh as a
minister I'm in a relatively comfortable
position compared to uh to to many
others so I think the right thing to do
is to make sure that we Safeguard people
with the energy price guarantee and we
also provide people with routes to get
the advice that they want on how to
minimize their energy usage we know that
you're a very healthy man we often see
you out running
um when you do need to go to the doctor
do you use a private GP uh I uh wherever
possible always use the NHS but I have
on occasion used private medicine
um we know that the Prime Minister does
that as well is that what do you think
that says about the optics for people
when they have to wait a fortnight for
their GP and the boss who is in charge
of of that system can spend 250 quid and
just I think the most important thing is
making sure that all of us do what we
can in order to ensure that the NHS gets
the resources that it needs
so you support him using a private GP
when he wants to uh I think everybody
that's got enough money should use a
private GP to take pressure off the
system uh no I wouldn't give anyone else
any advice about their own Healthcare
choices
I have a question before I let you go
these pesky 100 ml bottles at the
airports apparently that's going to be
scrapped with these new scanners I don't
know if you've heard that or not
um how relieved are you about that
um well whenever I fly I always take a
minimum level of cosmetic and other
ambulance uh uh with me so I don't think
it will make much of a difference to me
but for those people whom it will make
flying more convenient I'm delighted
it's great to see you um take the water
with you we'll make your question thank
you very much indeed as always great